hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to live I own II
blondie why the windy windy windy windy
oh crap oh that that's hardly fair what
the hell I just got started
okay let's go
well that was surprising why why why
yeah they won't find me in the only
closet in the room they walk in like who
do I want to stab someone in the butt
but no gears like you Wendy and she goes
blondie and they're like mom lime and
big purple love and pile over in the
corner there and I don't want to think
about that ever again sorry to put that
visual in your head everybody so anyway
never gonna talk about that ever again I
hey guys her ocean Tucker oh you're okay
yeah but I twisted my ankle I'll wait
here for a bit that's not a good thing
okay I found this a little while ago
take it with you I found the item
vinegar what am I gonna do make a salad
here thanks so much
Tucker Oh or should I say cut do show
next one markiplier Thank You markiplier
self-five nice thick burn okay anyway
that was sad it was really really sad
what was that the only thing over here
was that literally the only thing over
here get some vinegar well that guy
hides in the closet waits for death he's
gonna die and then he's gonna turn into
one of the monsters and then I'm gonna
have to run away from him too and then
I'm not gonna be happy whatever so what
do I do with this vinegar soaked up okay
soak that red key you do that the rust
fell off okay
iron gate key and I know exactly where
there is an iron gate this is good this
is good this is a bonding experience
this grow
this is growing for us all I'm so glad
that we could go through this together
and I'm learning from my mistake in
closing the gate behind me all right
what do we got in here
ooh paintings there's a TV or something
is this a jail the house a monster there
is a button under the painting press the
button uh no press the button no press
the button yes
yeah press that button yes yes I
oppressed all of the button now I wait
for the entire place to self destruct
and destroy all these things and send
them back to Hell where they belong okay
maybe not
so okay it seems like I've got a puzzle
here that has no clue everybody just
settle back markiplier is trying to
solve a puzzle is gonna be funny to
watch so let's look at this objectively
blue red yellow blue red yellow primary
colors blue red yellow what do we do
about you you son of a [ __ ] was there
something in my inventory that could
help me with this oh there isn't good
great how about I just start slamming
him down in a certain order
okay did that let me try this oh this
and that
nope that didn't work how about this of
that okay so I can't solve this this is
good I'm getting out of here Taku Oh
give me something actually useful
besides vinegar you know I could have
tried you know my guys sets it in in
here he could have tried to put the red
key in the key holes you know he could
have just like
I don't know I'm just as dumb as the
purple I am a monster I've already known
that so not a painting puzzle and the
sad thing about this painting puzzles
that I have no idea what I'm doing
oh no idea what I'm doing
ever ever so I'm just gonna sit here and
be a [ __ ] I wish I could look at that
picture book again maybe that adds some
clue to it it's the only bit of color in
this entire place what order has I not
done this in there's only so many orders
no don't don't do that unless I need to
repeat some maybe I leave the room each
time I don't know don't don't look at
anything goes anything I'm not doing
anything I'm not doing anything at all
what are you talking about what let me
see how do you spell walk no I'm not I'm
not I swear I would never I would never
I would never I would never what what oh
wait no sudden brain wave whoa whoa just
got knowledge injected into my face I'm
actually gonna close that nothing's not
about closing nothing I'm doing what why
why what are you looking at were you
looking at we do you want fight breath
you want to fight you want to fight bro
you wanna you want to you want to go you
want to go you want to go you want to go
it was wait what it said well I said
something about and finally I said
something about a rug ah here wait no
here
aha found the item disc that's all I
looked at I swear that's all I look I
didn't see anything else so I got a disc
it's not gonna help me
ah wait red yellow yellow blue yellow
red all right that would have been
impossible to guess you got you got it
I would have been running around for
hours that save some time that's all I
looked at I didn't look at a I didn't I
closed the window it's gone
please so dad yellow yellow blue yellow
red piece of candy ooh please candy
I found a metal stick what do I do with
a metal stick it's a key not a stick you
doofus what sure good great that's a
thing see he can make he can make random
light leaps of logic as well just like I
can so don't judge us don't judge me
hidden door key in the hidden door oh
good I was wondering when we were gonna
go down into a deep dark cavern of
misery and despair unless ice can get me
the hell out of here maybe is there
gonna be a monster that kind of like
pokes out of his head like there's a
bear sorry did you just crap your pants
I should bring tokoro here unless Takuro
is a monster Tokoro probably a monster
I'm just gonna say that right now oh
he's not oh he's not are you serious her
ocean yeah I'm serious
tokoro joined the party Wow look at him
he's got he's just as pathetic it would
be as I am but somehow he's able to walk
with his hurt ankle this isn't gonna go
something is gonna go wrong here
something is gonna go wrong
oh wow I didn't even give me a chance
oh you didn't even give me a chance what
the hell you didn't even give me a
chance
oh man I was mourning tokoro knows
mourning the loss of my friend
you just snuck up and stabbed me in the
butt
why cereal blonde but stabber oh you're
not the blonde bud Stamper you're the
original but stabber
you're the ball but stabber yeah yeah
the tasty tasty I've lost my best friend
hey that's hardly fair to say okay good
god stay that way what happened to him
is he gonna turn into a monster is he
gonna be the redheaded monster now hello
what's this backdoor key backdoor key
backdoor know what I don't remember any
back door anywhere must be something I
guess
but what where where in the world is
there a back door key where in the world
is there a back door I'm really confused
I don't know what am I
I don't recall there being a back door
indeed Center any place back there maybe
I actually do got to go back to the
front of the house and try to find
there's that wind whistling through this
place again but I don't think I'm
supposed to be back here no no this is
not right this is not right there's got
to be something over there but what
there's got to be something right I'm
I'm hey wait a minute
maybe no kitchen library bathroom no no
no no it's got to be back there I didn't
need to come back all this way so I'm
being delusional in delirious delusional
and delirious I'll be over on the right
Avenue in just a hot second no no it's
all wrong it's gone all wrong there's
gotta be something else back here I
think maybe okay where where is there
back door in the annex am I in the annex
I'm in the annex am I in the annex I
don't know I don't know I don't know
these things where is the annex where oh
where no don't I didn't the stupid
closet let's actually wait let me look
in the closet that tokoro was in unless
there's like a secret backdoor hidden in
the wall how do I know if I'm in the
attics how do I know where anything is
no don't be dumb her ocean
doctor in the annex where oh where did
this take me
backdoor in the annex stop at stop it
there you go back to over here no I am
at a complete and total loss I am so
lost and so lost I don't know up here
I don't recall there being a single
other lock door anywhere anywhere in
this house I am NOT I am at a total loss
and I but I will keep at this until I
find it oh man okay I've got I've got
items that I have had for a while and I
don't know what to do with like if I
look at my inventory I've still got the
screwdriver with a flat head that's fine
I've got the plate shard from the
beginning but I've also got this light
bulb that I have no idea what to do with
there's got to be some place to put the
light bulb in right it's got to be a
place this is where the other guy hung
himself this creepy ass dolls
empty thing there I turn out the lights
and I turn on the lighter here can I
find something no I don't think so
there's this doll here there's a
headless doll here cuz I took the head
there and I put it over there if I go
upstairs there's a monster trying to get
me all right I don't want to look at the
walkthrough again I don't I could get
this you get this okay all right wait in
every other time it's all about or of
using everything on everything but
there's some strange logic that is
always persevere
in games right there's always some
strange logic if I were a light bulb a
blight heat like fireplace I don't know
I'm reaching here really really that's
where the light bulb goes
why why why why would that be a thing
okay what do I do about that it's in the
light I put a light bulb in a doll's
head good for me
whoa all right if I turn the lights out
will that go on yep what what is that
what is that it's a big-ass shadow
leading into the wall here something
seems off about this wallpaper oh really
Wow on the back door key yeah I don't
understand there's no way there's no way
that makes any sort of sense there's no
way that makes sense
what the hell what the hell okay where
am I now where the hell am I now that is
absolutely ridiculous you can't even
begin to say that that's any sort of
making any sort of sense screw you screw
your face all right then
whatever it won't open okay we're back
to playing this game are we the v's
won't open game can I move this no can I
go up here no is there anything
available in here no is there a quarter
of the rug that needs to be moved
no anything in the plastic no all right
so now that we're here a lesson to you
guys and what I've learned from playing
these silly silly RPGs even the craziest
thought might be right
the more you know and this is strange
why is this here
what kind of strange mansion was this
supposed to be
what was his blaze used for I saw that
slightly different color and I got a
stick out of it
the hole is too dark to see down it's
too dangerous to climb how about we
poked a stick down there long stick ha
ha ha I'll poke my long stick down there
Wow Wow
okay whatever shut up everybody shut up
we got this going on nothing nothing at
all really you just decide like hey this
seems like a good place to stick my head
off why not
damn it I'm not gonna be able to get
away from you am i there we go good good
good good good stay that way why that we
I mean stay down and dead and stupid so
anyway I'm actually all that time I went
over I was got a little excited about
whatever the hell went on with that last
one but anyway so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation more
videos it I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video
walking here has a really
Oh
on a gurney
look